سيد الرئيس اعضاء
المحكمه
انا اتشرف بان اكون امامكم وتحدث باسم
افريقيا هذه ال قضيه
والمحاكمه مبنيه على الماده
تاسعه من
معاهده الاباده الجماعيه
وم
والمحكمه سوف
تقرر اذا كانت اسرائيل تصرفت بما ينتهك
هذه المعاهده هذا سيتم في مرحله لاحقه
الامر يتعلق الان فقط به ما هي
التدابير المؤقته او الاحترازيه التي يمكن
اتخاذها قبل
اتخاذ القرار هناك
خمس متطلبات لهذه
ال
اجراءات الناحيه
القانونيه والبروفيسور دوغارد سيتحدث عن
ذلك وثانيا غ ان يكون هناك ربط بين
الاجراءات وبين الحقوق المطالب
بها وسيكون هناك مطالبه بامر ان اسرائيل
لا تنتهك
القانون الذي تنص
عليه ينص عليه طلب اسم افريقيا كذلك هناك
الانسجام والرئيس
د اوضح ذلك حق الحق المطالب به هو جزء لا
يتجزا من الاتفاق
اقيه دون ذكر الحق في ان يتم التعرض للقتل
او للاصابه البالغه او
سطحيه رابعا وخامسا ينبغي ان يكون هناك
خطر لوجود ضرر كبير قابل لان
يحدث نتيجه لعدم اتخاذ هذه
القرارات وقد تم التحدث عن هذه النقاط
اسرائ قامت على مدى ثلاثه
شهور بالقصف
في على
غزه
المحاصره ولا يمكن ان ينظر الى ذلك على
انها محاوله لتدمير غزه
وسكانها وهم يقولون ايضا اعلنا انهم سوف
يستمرون في القيام
بذلك ونحن على علم
ب مدى
وحجم القتل
والدمار ومستمرون في هذه اللحظه بالذات في
القيام
بذلك ان واجبات
الدول
لتجنب القيام بمثل هذه
الانتهاكات يكون بحسب معرفه المخاطر
الواضحه من هذه الجريمه ومنذ تلك اللحظه
اذا
كانت كان لدى الدوله التي تقوم بهذه
الاعمال علم بانها باثار
ذلك ف من
واجبها ان تستخدم هذه الادوات بحسب
المتاح
وذلك ما تقوم به جنوب افريقيا من خلال
تقديم هذا
الطلب في حالات مثل جراند فينا
جاد المحاكمه استخدمت حقها في اصدار او في
اتخاذ
قرارات
مؤقته وذلك
لتفادي او
لتفادي الضرر
للافراد وقد اصدرت
اوامر لمنع الدول من قتل
افراد بطريقه تنتهك القانون
الدولي وذلك ما تطالب به جنوب
افريقيا بعد ان تعرض اكثر من 23 ال للقتل
في خلال حصار وقصف
غزه
واغلبيه كبرى منه همرج رجال ونساء واطفال
ابرياء المحكمه ايضا تصدر مثل هذه الاوامر
لحمايه حياه
وسلامه الافراد مثلا في البوسني بوسنا
والهرسك عدم اتخاذ اي عمل والتاكد من عدم
اتخاذ اي عمل
قد يزيد من
خطوره
ووقع هذه الاعمال على الافراد ومما قد
يصعب التوصل الى
حل وبدون هذه الاوامر بعدم زياده
المخاطر
فان المعتدي سوف يعجل الى اكمال عملته قبل
ان تتخذ المحكمه قرارها
النهائي
اذا جنوب افريقيا حافظت على هذا طلبها هذا
ضمن اطار
القانون قد نتساءل
لماذا لا
تطالب جنوب افريقيا بقرار ضد
حماس هذه الحاله تتعلق
بغزه لانه كان هناك قرار من مجلس الامن
الذي
اشار الى
اتخاذ
اجراءات وذلك منذ عام
1967 حماس ليست
دوله ولا يمكن ان تكون طرفا في
معاهده منع الاباده
الجماعيه
وهناك جهات اخرى وعمليات اخرى يمكن ان
تبادر اتخاذ هذه مثل هذه القضايا لدى
المحكمه وهي مساله
قانون في اطار هذه المعاهده وجنوب افريقيا
لا يمكن ان تطالب باتخاذ قرار ضد حماس
ثانيا جنوب افريقيا تفهم انه ليس كل مظهر
من مظاهر العنف يعتبر
اباده ربما هناك تطهير العرقي هناك العقاب
الجماعيه هناك استهداف المدنيين الهجمات
ضد المستشفيات وكل واي هجمات اخرى كلها
اجرام حرب ولكنها لا
تنتهك
اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه الاباده
الجماعيه هي
تدمير بشكل كلي او جزئي
لمجموعه ما وما تقوم به اسرائيل في غزه
يمثل جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه ولا دفاع ولكن
لذلك ليس تماما اباده
جماعيه في الماده 111 من هذا
الطلب هناك طلب لاجراء
احترازيه او
مؤقته السبب وراء ذلك هو سبب
نفعي وهذه المواد تدعو
الى تعليق العمليات
العسكريه ضد
غزه
و العمليات المستمره في غزه منذ 7 اكتوبر
هي محل تركيز
لهذه الحاله ونذكر بان جنوب افريقيا قد
ادانت هجمه السابع من
اكتوبر واسرائيل تقول انها لا
تستهدف الفلسطينيين وسكان غزه تريد ان تح
تقضي على حماس ولكن
الاستمرار للقصف و تسويه العديد من
المباني بالارض وقطع الماء والكهرباء
والغذائي والتواصل على شعب باكمله لا يمكن
ان
تكون عذرا
لتعقب اعضاء حماس انه هجوم
اعمى يقتل
ويرعب الشعب باكمله في غزه بدون اي اعتبار
لمساله براءه
او ذنب
ارتكبوه
وتدمر اي
امكانيه لعودتهم ليست انفوا حياتهم بين
الركام اعمال اسرائيل بالهجوم على
الفلسطينين في غزه بشكل مباشر ومنع وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه
اليهم الفلسطينيون يواجهون الموت بسبب
القصف
المستمر والموت من الجوع والامراض
وهو
اكثر صعوبه
وفضاء في الايام الاخيره الولايات المتحده
قالت مره ان هناك عددا اكبر بكثير مما
ينبغي يموتون في غزه وكذلك الامين العام
لامم المتحده والمبعوث الخاص الامم
المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه اقول انه من
الضروري توقف الاعمال
العسكريه من اجل تمكين
التوزيع العادل للمساعدات
الانسانيه لذلك فان جنوب افريقيا طلبت
امرا بالتعليق الفوري للعمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في
غزه وهي الطريقه الوحيده
لضمان الرد
الانساني ولتفادي المزيد من الموت غير
المبرر بين
الفلسطينيين ينبغي ان نؤكد على
انه ليس هناك لا يكفي ان نقول ان على
اسرائيل ان تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه للحد
من الاضرار ومن
الضحايا هناك استخدام ذخائر
مدمره قصف مستمر لغزه وحتى للمناطق التي
قيل عنها انها غير امنه ووجهت اسرائيل
الناس
اليها لكن ليست هذه هي النقطه الوحيده
ليست ليست مسالت فقط حجم وعدم تمييز هي
مساله
نيه لو ان اي عمليه عسكريه مهما تم مهما
كانت الاحتياطات التي يتم
اتخاذها للا تنفي النيه بالقضاء على
شعب وينبغي ان تتوقف هذه العمليه لذلك فان
جميع العمليات
العسكريه يمكنها ان تتوقف ينبغي ان
تتوقف الطلب الثالث هو اصدار
امر بالنظر مع واجبات التي تقع على جنوب
افريقيا في الدفاع عن ما يحدث هو اتخاذ
جميع الاجراءات لتفادي اكتمال الاباده وال
الاجراء الرابع والخامس هي
واجبات ذات شكل عام وهي موجوده في الماده
رقم واحد واثنين وثلاثه من الاتفاقيه
الاجراء
السادس
يتعلق بكون ان بان حكومه اسرائيل ملزمه
قانونيا على تفادي
من يتعاملون او
يدعمون
ويمارسون عمليات تمثل انتهاكا لهذه
المعاهده قبل 36 ساعه السلطات الاسرائيليه
لم تفعل اي شيء
لايقاف الكلام الداعي الى الاباده من قبل
مسؤولين
سياسيين وهي تطبيع مثل هذه الدعوات والحث
على
الاباده ولذلك فان
هذا اجراء ضروري او مطالب
به هناك ايضا مصداقيه اسرائيل وسمعتها في
المحك او على
المحك وما يمكنه ان يحق يثبت ان
هناك شيئا يدل على وجود هذه
النيه
وينبغي وهو منع الصحفيين من ان يقوم
بعملهم الاعلامي من
غزه واخيرا جنوب افريقيا تطلب من
المحكمه ان تطلب تقارير عن من
غزه حول اسرائيل وما ينبغي القيام به
وهناك هذه التقارير يتم نشرها من قبل
المحكمه وتمثل عنصرا
مهما
بالنسبه
ل اذا
منتق ساعلق الان على مبدا الدفاع عن النفس
هنالك فتوى قانونيه تحاجج فيها اسرائيل
وتبرر فيها التدمير الذي تسببه في الحرب
وطبعا هذه نابعه من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل تمارس السيطره
عليها ولهذه الاسباب فان المحكمه قررت
وكبدا من مبادئ القانون الدولي فان حق
الدفاع عن النفس وفقا للماده 51 من ميثاق
الامم
المتحده لا علاقه له بالامر في مثل هذه
الظروف قبل 20 يوما مجلس الامن اكد مره
اخرى على ان غزه تعتبر اراضي محتله وارض
محتله وغزه تشير الى انها انسحبت و بشكل
كامل من غزه ولكنها احتفظت
بالسيطره كامله على غزه من خلال البر
والجو والبحر وكذلك من خلال السيطره على
عدد من المهام الاداريه والتي تحدد فيها
ايصال الكهرباء والماء وغيرها واحكمت
قبضتها على غزه وما من شك بان هذا هو
الواقع
الحقيقي
و رايا قانونيا في عام 2014 ايضا يؤكد ذلك
وهنالك حجه م ثله يمكن الاخذ بها هنا ما
تقوم ما الذي تقوم به اسرائيل في غزه هي
موجوده على اراض تسيطر عليها وبالتالي فان
افعالها وما تقوم به
هو تنفيذ لاحتلالها ووفقا للماده 51 من
ميثاق الامم المتحده لا تطبق ليس لها
تطبيق هنا ولكن ليست هذه النقطه الاساسيه
النقطه الاساسيه هنا هي اكثر بساطه من ذلك
بغض النظر عن
مدى فداحه وجسام الهجوم او الاستفزاز لا
تكون الاباده جماعيه هي الرد المناسب على
اي افعال مروعه او فضيعه ان استخدام اي
شكل من اشكال القوه سواء من مبدا الدفاع
عن ال نفس او من مبدا الاحتلال او من مبدا
تنفيذ عمليات عسكريه ينبغي ان يبقى ضمن
الحدود التي وضعها وكرس القانون الدولي
بما في ذلك الواجب الاساسي الوارد في
الماده 51 من ميثاق الامم المتحده والقاضي
بمنع اعمال الاباده الجماعيه جنوب افريقيا
تؤمن بان الادله المتوفره بشان حجم الدمار
الناجم عن عمليات القصف التي طالت غزه
وكذلك القيود المتعمده المفروضه على دخول
المياه الماء المياه والغذاء والادويه
وكذلك الاحتياجات الاساسيه الواجب توفيرها
للمواطنين في غزه يثبت ويبرهن على ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وليس الشعب اليهودي
وليس الشعب
الاسرائيلي اقول ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وجيشها ينوي تدمير الفلسطينيين في غزه
كمجموعه ولا تقوم باي شيء لمنع او معاقبه
افعال لجهات اخرى تدعم هذا الطرح واكرر ان
الامر لا يتعلق ب تصرف اسرائيل العشوائي
المساله هنا تتعلق ب بمنع الاباده
الجماعيه والذي يعد ركنا اساسيا في
القانون ولا يوجد شيء يبرر اي عمل من
اعمال الاباده الجماعيه بغض النظر عن عما
يقوم به بعض الافراد ضمن الفلسطينيين ما
قام به بعض الافراد من بين الفلسطينيين
والتهديد الذي يمكن ان
واجه الشعب الاسرائيلي فان ولا يبرر مثل
هذا الهجوم الذي ينم عن اباده جماعيه تشمل
غزه ونيه تدميرها اذا هذا امر لا يمكن
تبريره باي شكل من الاشكال و ليس هنالك اي
استثناءات تسمح لدوله للانخراط في اعمال
يمكن ان تفضي الى انتهاك التزاماتها بموجب
معاهده منع الاباده الجمعيه لا يمكن تخيل
ان المحكمه يمكن ان تفعل امر كهذا وهذه
النقطه بديهيه هنا في هذه القضيه لا يمكن
تبرير اعمال الاباده الجماعيه في اي تحت
اي ظرف من
الظروف ان افعال اسرائيل واعمالها سيتم
تمحيصها وتدقيق فيها في مرحله النظر في
موضوع الدعوه وليس شكلها وسنستمر الى
مرافعات اسرائيل الدفاعيه ما هو مهم الان
هو ان الادله تشير الى ان افعال
اسرائيل تؤكد انتهاك التزامات اسرائيل
وتعهداتها بموجب معاهده او اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه وانها عازمه نيه وعقده
على الاستمرار في مثل هذه الاعمال اسرائيل
قد تقول او تحاجج بانها تلتزم بكامل
التزاماتها وتعهداتها بموجب اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه وان رفع دعوه امام هذه
المحكمه غير ضروري ولكن في حالات اخرى
اكدت اكدت المحكمه بان تصري ريحات فرديه
لا يمكن ان يرفع او يلغي حق المحكمه في
نظري في دعون كهذه احد الاسباب التي يمكن
ان تشكك في مثل هذا الاجراء الفردي هو
قدره
اسرائيل او قولها بانها لم ترتكب اي خطا
من خلال اقتحامها لغزه وتدمير غزه وشعبها
وتحويلها الى
رماد الامر يتعلق ب تفسير اي عمل احادي
تقوم به اسرائيل وهذا قد يؤدي الى
انعكاسات و وتبعات مروعه بحيث لا يمكن
التساهل مع الخطر المرتبط بذلك ولكن هناك
سبب ثالث كما اشرنا في مرحله تقديم الدعوه
امام هذه المحكمه
وكذلك ما ورد من تحفظات في ان ان
الالتزامات
بشان المنازعه بشان تنفيذ او تطبيق هذه
المعاهده تحت مظله المحكم محكمه العدل
الدوليه ياتي ضمن الالتزام الاساسي
المتمثل في منع ومعاقبه جرائم الاباده
الجماعيه ان دور المحكمه هنا
والذي يتجاوز تفسير المعاهده
وتطبيقها ويتعدى ذلك الى
الايفاء بها هو امر اساسي وجوهري
فاضافة وان تحرص على الافاء بكل
الالتزامات التي نصت عليها معاهده او
اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه وربما
نستذكر قضيه في التاريخ القريب من التاريخ
القريب وهذه مهمه بالنسبه لمستقبل القانون
الدولي بالنسبه لمستقبل هذه المحكمه
السيده الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه الموقر
دعوني اختم
مرافعته بتقديم الشكر لكم على حسن
انتباهكم و
ويمكنكم التعويل على